why does it look like every video of
UFOs was filmed on a baked potato first
of all this is an intelligence if they
made these craft and they're Advanced
it's an intelligence so like I know when
you're trying to record me I'm aware of
your technology what says they're not
aware of ours the iPhone bro that is not
what you're seeing on the videos I'm
releasing what you're seeing in these
videos is you're seeing this layered
sensor systems so you're seeing Heat
Signature thermal that's the black and
white you're seeing infrared and
infrared is the light spectrum outside
of what the eye can see so if I take my
nvgs night vision goggles hold them up
like that to the sky the sky is littered
with stars your eye can't pick that up
but the nvg can so when you film through
that wow you can see whole spectrums of
light you can even film in the
ultraviolet you can get radar returns
you get optic systems that are so
powerful so that is a false argument
that people make even Neil the grass
Tyson he needs to like start thinking
and not just talking